No matter where they live, the Elves sure
know how to decorate.
So what's so important about the Elvish realm
of Lindon in Amazon's "The Rings of Power"?
Now that "The Lord of the Rings: The Rings
of Power" is officially out, audiences are
seeing several Middle-earth regions through
a time-traveling lens, including Lindon.
The Elvish nation technically shows up in
"The Lord of the Rings" for a short sequence
at the very end of the story, when Frodo and
Bilbo hop on a ship at the Grey Havens.
But by that point, the area is a skeletal
remnant of the powerful Faerie kingdom that
exists there during "The Rings of Power" narrative
— which is set during the Second Age of
Middle-earth history.
During that story, the elf-capital Lindon
is a powerhouse.
Lindon is one of the last major strongholds
of Elven glory before the Elder Children of
Ilúvatar fade away, replaced by the young,
up-and-coming race of Men.
"The time has come for the dominion of men."
Here's a quick breakdown of the Elven Kingdom
and the crucial part that it plays in bridging
the gap between the epic Elder Days and "The
Lord of the Rings" story that fans know so well.
Technically speaking, Lindon doesn't exist
as a unified and structured kingdom until
the Second Age begins.
However, Elves live for a very long time,
and quite a few live in the area before it
becomes a proper kingdom.
"The Silmarillion" explains that the region
is initially called Ossiriand.
The Green-elves dwell there, living secluded
lives.
It reads,
"They were clad in green in spring and summer,
and the sounds of their singing could be heard
even across the waters of Gelion; wherefore
the Noldor named that country Lindon, the
land of music —"
"I hear it said that when you cross over,
you hear a song.
One whose memory we all carry."
When the First Age ends, the land to the west
of Lindon sinks in a catastrophic, world-breaking
event called the War of Wrath.
In the process, Lindon becomes the farthest
western point on the Middle-earth map.
Lindon is a major source of Elvish power during
the Second Age.
There are other areas where Elvish strongholds
pop up, but none of them rival Lindon.
Its leader is a fellow named Gil-galad.
He's the fourth and last "High King" of a
famous group of Elves called the Noldor.
His herald is a character that fans of "The
Lord of the Rings" are quite familiar with
— a Half-elven dude named Elrond.
When Lindon is founded, Elrond is eons away
from his future as a wise and mighty counselor
and the leader of Rivendell.
At this point, he's a very young Elf burdened
by incredible ancestry trying to find his
way in the world.
A couple of other important Elves spend time
in Lindon with these two key leaders.
The first is Galadriel, who may have lived
there before she left, leading Elves east
toward the Misty Mountains.
In "The Rings of Power" storyline, Galadriel
is more integrated into Lindon, serving, when
the show starts, as the Commander of its Northern
Armies.
The final Elf we can't fail to mention here
is Círdan, a famous shipbuilder who spends
his days helping his world-weary people leave
Middle-earth to set sail for the Blessed Realm
away in the West.
The first rise of Sauron defines the Second
Age of Middle-earth history.
In the Third Age that follows, Sauron re-emerges,
hunts for his Ring, and is ultimately toppled
by a Hobbit, a scrappy king in exile, and
a few other pretty important folks.
"Keep breathing.
That's the key.
Breathe."
In the Second Age, though, Sauron is just
starting to settle into his role.
The first thing he does is dress up in a handsome
physical form and call himself "Annatar, Lord
of Gifts."
He tries to dupe the Elves into thinking he's
a good guy that can help them.
This is how he ends up making a bunch of Rings
of Power with some of the Elves.
Before that happens, the folks in Lindon try
to stop him.
"The Silmarillion" explains,
"Only to Lindon he did not come, for Gil-galad
and Elrond doubted him and his fair-seeming,
and though they knew not who in truth he was
they would not admit him to that land."
Gil-galad and Elrond continue to doubt Sauron
in disguise until matters finally come to
a head about halfway through the Second Age.
Eventually, the secret gets out that Annatar
is Sauron after he, you know, makes the One
Ring and tries to control them directly and
stuff.
When that happens, war erupts, and Sauron
goes on the offensive.
Gil-galad lends Lindon's armies, under Elrond's
command, to resist Sauron's forces.
They fail, which leads to Elrond retreating
and founding Rivendell.
It's a setback, but Lindon itself isn't destroyed.
On the contrary, it turns into one of the
key areas of Middle-earth that Sauron can't conquer.
Many Elves use Lindon's havens during this
time to hightail it out of Middle-earth entirely,
but Gil-galad holds together enough of his
people to overcome the Dark Lord.
Over the rest of the Second Age, the fate
of Middle-earth swings back and forth.
Lindon continues to play a key role, and Gil-galad
receives help from the Men of Númenor.
The protracted, centuries-long drama ends
(temporarily, at least) when Gil-galad and
Elendil form the Last Alliance of Elves and
Men.
The group gathers and heads down south, where
both leaders are killed, and Elendil's son,
Isildur, cuts the One Ring from Sauron's hand.
After Sauron's first fall, the Third Age begins.
Lindon still exists as an area where Elves
dwell, but its power is greatly diminished.
So, while the area continues to be relevant
as an Elvish gateway from Middle-earth to
the Blessed Realm, otherwise its political
prowess is irrelevant.
Its king is dead.
Its new leader, Círdan, while a wise and
a masterful shipbuilder, isn't a High King
about to gather and lead the Elves to battle.
It's worth noting, though, that some of the
Wizards come through his havens, and he even
gives one of them an Elven Ring to help him
with his mission — Gandalf.
"It's Gandalf!"
Even though there isn't much else going on,
the area continues to be distinctly important
— and very Elvish.
The Hobbits, who settle down in the nearby
Shire halfway through the age, have stories
of the area.
So, in the end, Lindon slowly fades into a
forgotten Elvish realm lost on the edge of
the Middle-earth story.
But it doesn't change the fact that it plays
a prominent role in the Second Age — an
age that "The Rings of Power" series is about
to explore in detail.